this episode is sponsored by 80 000
hours 80 000 is a non-profit that aims
to help people have a positive impact
with their careers head to 80 thousand
hours.org microcosmos to start planning
a career that could potentially help
solve one of the world's most pressing
problems
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
from our vantage point as relatively
large organisms it can be easy to
overlook the micro cosmos because
it is simply too small to see
it floats in front of our eyes at all
times and yet we cannot make out any of
the details until we turn to other tools
and then
even when we do turn to those tools it
can be easy to overlook the parts of the
microcosmos that seem relatively
understated compared to all of the
wondrous dramatic events that can take
place after all
if you just come from say watching a
tardigrade wandering through a maze of
moss you might find something like this
a bit underwhelming there's just
some squishy dots floating around not
doing anything particularly noteworthy
except for a few brief flashes of
movement the movement is so quick that
you might see it and just move on to
something else like when you glimpse a
bird flying out of the corner of your
eye it captures your attention for a
second and perhaps it releases it just
as quickly but for today because we're
us we're gonna linger on that moment and
let it capture our attention a little
longer because the organism you're
looking at right now is a ciliate called
cyclidium which is known for its ability
to dart straight through the microcosmos
like an arrow it's only a few
micrometers in length but packed in its
small body is the ability to detect
threats and quickly jump out of their
reach
this is not the first time that we've
seen a very very fast-moving ciliate on
this channel early on we watched as
bundles of the bell-shaped vorticella
extended their long stocks and then
rapidly contracted those stalks into
tightly packed spirals when other
organisms got too close
we've also watched asperostimum quickly
evade unwanted contact pulling back and
shrinking down to get itself out of
reach as quickly as possible
we can think of the vorticella and
spirostomum as doing something that's
more like flinching a rapid contraction
that moves them away from a potential
threat but that doesn't necessarily
transport them to a whole new location
it's remarkable and requires both
tremendous force and speed but ciliates
like the cyclidium we were watching
earlier or these halteria are performing
a very different sort of athleticism
something
more like a long jump
not that they look like they should be
setting any records halteria are only
around 20 microns in length and most of
the time they just kind of spin
like a kid on a teacup ride with no
concept of dizziness and charmingly the
halteria is edged in cilia that swirls
with it unfurling as it moves and then
wrapping back inward as the organism
winds down
alteria like to feed on bacteria and
they reproduce quickly so sometimes
james our master of microscopes will
find thousands of them in a single drop
another set of squishy dots that move in
and out of focus sometimes even
obscuring the other interesting bits
that james is trying to look at but
let's zoom out past the point where we
can see the defined lines of the
hultarius cilia where it really is just
one dot navigating a field of debris and
see if you can keep up with it
most of the time it's not really a
challenge it looks like a floater in
your vision a clear blob that just idles
away but then
seemingly out of nowhere it leaps across
the screen and out of view potentially
traveling as far as 100 times its own
body length in a single second that
would be like if i a six-foot human
being could leap 600 feet in a second
in response to this you might say
something like okay yeah sure hank but
you're a human being things are
different in the microcosmos and yes
this is true things really are different
in the micro cosmos in fact things are a
lot more challenging organisms like
halteria are living in water but because
of their small size that water feels
like thick molasses so they have to rely
on structures like cilia to help them
swim and move quickly but even then most
organisms only travel around 10 times
their body length in a single second the
fact that halteria and a select group of
other leaping ciliates are able to jump
a hundred times their body length in
that same second is
incredible and we don't know
exactly what it is that makes these
impressive hops possible but it does
require a lot
of energy so it makes sense that in its
off moments the alteria prefers to be a
little bit more static and there are a
few other members of this elite jumping
ciliate group like the strumbidium you
see here leaping around it is very
impressive that james can even keep up
with them and that of course is the
point not to avoid james the ciliates
are not aware of him but the goal of
this movement is to help the ciliate be
overlooked to ensure that predators
cannot find them and it works the
slightest brush of a predator's presence
sends these ciliates into escape mode in
one experiment researchers set some
rotifers upon a population of halteria
and found that only 12 percent of them
ended up as rotifer food another leaping
ciliate called strobolydium was even
more successful at evading capture with
only three percent of them getting eaten
there is however one notable exception
to this predator evasion while halteria
might be able to escape rotifers they
have a dedicated predator called the
actinibolina which we have talked about
before
this tentacled toxin-loaded ciliate
could go after anything it wanted but
for some reason it dines exclusively on
halteria
why
and how
no clue
maybe they just got lucky to live in an
environment that was rich enough in
halteria that through evolution the
actinibolina was able to learn how to
sneak up on their cagey prey
so perhaps it is not possible for them
to always be overlooked eventually
someone will take a moment to appreciate
them
if they are unfortunate it is the one
predator that has managed to find a way
around their tricks but sometimes
it's just us
slowing down just enough to catch a
glimpse of something so much faster and
so much smaller than we are
thanks for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us and thanks again to 80 000
hours for sponsoring today's episode 80
000 hours is a non-profit that aims to
help people have a positive impact with
their career the direction of your
career path is a big life decision and
80 000 hours has a lot of free resources
to help you plan and research what
options might be best for you they've
got fantastic free resources including
decision making tools a constantly
updated job board and even a podcast
where they have in-depth conversations
with experts in the world's most
pressing problems and they discuss what
you can do to help solve them in one of
their recent episodes they discussed
what's being done on the cutting edge of
malaria control and treatment and the
state-of-the-art efforts that are going
towards trying to create a malaria-free
world
80 thousand hours wants to help you find
a career that does good in the world and
all of their provided resources are free
they're a non-profit and their only aim
is to help you find a fulfilling
high-impact career check out our link in
the description or go to 80000 hours.org
microcosmos to be sent a free copy of
their in-depth career guide and to start
learning how you could have a
high-impact career this will also sign
you up for their newsletter where they
send updates on their research and
high-impact job opportunities
all the names on the screen right now
are the names of people who decided
today would be a reason why journey to
the micro cosmos is able to exist and
keep making such delightful little bits
of content as this one so if you're
looking for somebody to thank it's these
folks right here and if you're
interested in becoming one you can go to
patreon.com
journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
[Music]